what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video now that we have
seen several promos photos and trailers
for this season we have a fair amount of
evidence for us to get a decent grasp on
what may or may not take place during
season seven and I'm sure by now that
most of you have read or heard about the
plot league that came out back in
October but there was also an extended
version of that plot leak that came out
about a month after that
and in that extended version it appeared
to have all the gaps filled in for each
scene during each episode so I want to
take another look at one of those
particular episodes because there were a
few things that I've seen in the new
trailers that may be small indicators
that can determine whether this is going
to be true or not because if this leaked
episode ends up being true then it's
going to be absolutely insane and
arguably one of the best ever but that
could also mean that Jon Snow will die
once again so let's read the scenes for
this episode then see if any of the
released evidence matches up obviously
there's going to be some massive
spoilers in this video so proceed with
caution my friends this leak is for
episode 6 which is the episode right
before the finale
since this is a shortened season then
this episode should be one of the most
explosive episodes in the entire season
the leaked episode says that Jon Snow
Jorah Mormont Theon Greyjoy Davos
Seaworth and Gendry arrived at Castle
black Lord Commander edie and Jon Snow
reunite edie tells John that the
Brotherhood without banners showed up at
Castle black earlier that day and they
were with the Hound Poorman and Brienne
apart it says Gendry forgives Thoris and
beric Dondarrion for selling him to
Melisandre Barrack then tells everyone
that Jon Snow is azor Ahai in apparently
Davos and Foreman agree with this John
tells the Brotherhood and the men from
the Nights Watch about his plan to go
capture a white Davos plans to stay at
the wall and right Daenerys a letter
saying that if she comes and helps then
Jon will lay down his title as king in
the north
next it said that John and Davos give
everyone some dragonglass that they were
able to get off of Dragonstone and after
this everyone heads north of the wall
except for Davos John takes some
wildlings and men from the Nights Watch
with him they end up running into a
white that is wall
the hound tries to subdue this white but
it escapes which causes the hound to
chase after it the group of characters
are able to corner the white between a
cliff of frozen lake in the woods but
the white jumps off a cliff and as the
white is falling down this cliff you can
actually see thousands of whites
climbing up it and as this is happening
hundreds of whites start to emerge from
the woods so now John and his companions
are stuck on the edge of a cliff as
whites are climbing up the cliff and the
whites are coming out of the woods
completely surrounding them forests of
Marin beric Dondarrion ting make their
swords and begin the attack the whites
on the cliff make it to the top and
start attacking the group from behind
Lord Commander ed is killed immediately
as well as a few other men from the
Nights Watch White Walkers then start to
emerge from the woods and one of them is
riding a giant ice spider force of
mirrors then killed by a zombie polar
bear that seemed to come out of nowhere
The Hound tried to save him but was
unsuccessful a white Walker with dull
blade starts to attack Jon Jon ends up
being killed by the white Walker after
his ice sword is plunged into his gut
Brienne kills that white Walker with
Oathkeeper Jorah Mormont then walks over
to John's dead body and he picks up long
claw and begins to attack a member from
the Brotherhood without banners is able
to kill another white Walker with a
dragon glass arrow tip Gendry then
smashes in the whites face with his
Warhammer and this is when the knight
teen gets off of his horse and fights
back with his flaming sword after barek
is mortally wounded by the night king
Daenerys shows up on her dragon and she
has vissarion flying ray by her side
Drogo immediately starts to torch dozens
of White's and while this is all going
on beric Dondarrion crawls over to
John's dead body and he gives him the
kiss of life
berrak dies and john is now alive again
Daenerys his dragons start to clear a
path with fire so that the group can
escape back to the wall the Hound is
finally able to subdue a wight and take
it with him but one of the white walkers
hits Drogo him with a nice spear causing
him and Daenerys to fly away erratically
the night king then plunges an ice spear
into vissarion's eye which kills the
dragon john gets up off the ground and
he picks up Barracks flaming sword and
immediately starts killing several
whites Jorah then gives Longclaw
to John but John is nearly disarmed once
again as he gets surrounded by more
whites but his uncle Benjen shows up and
he puts the injured John on his horse
and he whispers goodbye nephew as John
rides away on benjin's horse he
helplessly watch his benjin get swarmed
by dozens of whites and presumably
killed right as the episode is about to
end the night King raises the dead
dragon Viserion and right as the screen
is about to fade to black we see
vissarion's eyes turn blue okay so now
let's look at the evidence and see if
any of this matches up or not because if
this is true and jon snow dies again
this is going to be a crazy-ass episode
first it says Jon Davos viang Jorah and
Gendry all arrived together at Castle
black we have seen plenty of photos to
prove that all of these characters will
be in the same location at the same time
Jon Davos Jorah and Gendry are all seen
here together near this boat and we have
also seen Jon and Filan together on this
beach as well so it's possible that
beyond does go to further proof his
loyalty and continued his Redemption
argh we also know that Jon will be north
of the wall with at least 12 characters
but there could also be more than twelve
characters initially some people might
have possibly died already before we see
them here surrounded on the frozen lake
in the trailer so it's also possible
that Lord Commander edy and marina parth
go we already know for a fact that
tormund the Hound barrack force and
Gendry are going to be there we've seen
most of them in the trailer fighting
north of the wall some of you had even
said that this might be Brienne running
alongside Jon Snow in the first trailer
we know that Brienne will show up at
Winterfell when Jon is there so he might
tell her that he's going to need her in
the future so she could decide to go
later on
Poorman might even get Breen to go with
him when he leaves and it's also very
likely that Jon will give everyone
dragonglass
we know from several reports that there
will be a scene where Jon Snow tells
everyone that they need to get
dragonglass and that it's worth more
than gold right now so Jon's most likely
going to get as much dragonglass as
possible while he's at Dragonstone
because he knows that it can kill White
Walkers so since they're going to be
going into white Walker territory it
would be wise of him to hand it out to
everyone that he could and it says that
the Hound tries to capture a white but
it runs and jumps off a cliff and as
it's falling there are thousands of
white
climbing up that cliff now this is very
interesting because in the newest
trailer we see exactly this you can
clearly see John and his team surrounded
by whites and John's men are fighting
whites coming from one side while John
is watching all the whites climb up this
cliff so far this part of this extended
leak is amazingly accurate and this is
when the white walkers are supposed to
emerge from the woods we know from the
trailer that they will definitely
encounter some white walkers too because
we can see John snow fighting a white
Walker one verse one in the new trailer
and it also says that Barracks going to
ignite its sword which we now know is a
fact because in the trailer we can see
barrack up north with his flaming sword
you can even see the flaming sword right
here behind John as the whites are
climbing up this cliff so this extended
leak is starting to look more and more
accurate and it also says that ginjury
is going to kill a white with his
Warhammer
we know Gendry is going to be here and
we know from the first trailer that he
will also have his Warhammer with them
so this is probably true also but I'm
pretty skeptical about the zombie polar
bear and ice spiders I mean we haven't
seen any evidence of that but that would
also be kind of stupid to reveal in the
trailer because that will be a great
what the [ __ ] moment for fans that
aren't very familiar with that part of
the story back in season war an old name
used to talk about ice spiders so I do
think we will see them at some point I
just haven't seen any evidence of that
yet
but they're going to be added with CGI
so there'd be no way to see them while
they're filming anyway so if we're going
to do it it might as well happen and
it's already chaotic scene but let's get
to the big part of this scene which is
Jon Snow dying and a dragon dying I know
there's been a few other youtubers
recently starting to talk about beric
possibly given Jon Snow the kiss of life
of their season but keep in mind I said
this over five months ago when I
released a video about this scene so
it's not a new prediction but the big
question is is this going to happen well
let's think about it for a second
because in the books
beric Dondarrion does give lady Catelyn
the kiss of life which then resurrect
her as Lady Stoneheart
so Barry Kevin this potential ability in
the show is bull Kanan Barrack does have
the power to do something like this and
since Barrack is dead in the books
already he will most likely die on this
mission right along with force of mirror
I'm not so sure Jon Snow is going to die
again but the actor who played
Jon Snow recently gave an interview and
he said something that was pretty
interesting in that interview that kind
of gave me a weird feeling Kit Harington
said that Jon Snow is in mortal danger
just like any other character this
season and there will be no more
resurrections for him now you can take
that at face value and believe that he's
telling the truth or there could be some
more misdirection from him this wouldn't
be the first time that he's lied about
the fate of his character he could have
said this just to throw people off but
I'm gonna let all of you be to judge
about that
I don't think Johnson was going to die
next season but that quotes saying he
won't be resurrected again kind of
Concerned me for some reason so I'm just
going to say that it's not out of the
possibility that Barrett will give him
the kiss of life next season but what
about miss Ariane will this dragon die
next season the leak says that Dany will
show up with their dragons there were a
few scenes from the new trailer that
make me believe this is going to be true
also there was one scene in the trailer
that shows the 19 on his horse and he
has like a knee-jerk reaction that
causes him to look directly into the sky
which might be him looking at the
Dragons also in one of the last scenes
in this trailer you can see Jon Snow's
staring down the barrel of hundreds of
whites but look behind all those whites
there are some big-ass fires everywhere
now how else would these big fires get
started all the way up here in the cold
ass north we know Derek let his sword
but what that really caused these big
bonfires back there I don't really think
so I think that was probably Daenerys
his dragons clearing a path for the
others could leave just like the leak
said and it also says that benjin is
going to show up and save Jon by sending
him off on his horse and the last scene
of the trailer does show someone riding
off on a black horse that looks just
like Benjamin's so in my honest opinion
I think most of this extended leak is
going to be true also now that we have
all this new evidence from the trailers
it seems to match up even more with this
leak I'm not so sure John's going to die
again like I said but I do think a
dragon will die for sure the xix will
have an equalizer if he gets his own
dragon but what do you all think have
you seen enough photos and promos and
trailers now to think this is what's
going to happen or are you still in the
fence about this stuff comment down
below and tell me what you think about
all this because I find it to be pretty
interesting to say the least but anyways
thanks for checking out the video I
really appreciate that and I
want to thank my patreon supporters also
I love you all and I'll see you down
below bye